[Music]
hi guys welcome back you know this is
the this is the called okay I'm Chris
D'Elia I got to do it like this I'm
Chris D'Elia and this is congratulations
the podcast that's not the title though
congratulations the podcast is just
congratulations and I'm Krystal your
host but you know it's actually weird to
say that you're a host when it's just
you but it's going to be just me and so
it's just kind of my show anyway uh hi
welcome this is the second episode I
think unless this might be the first
episode because I did record an episode
already and it was very short but I
don't know if I was even going to post
it up yet I didn't post it up yet so I
didn't post this one up yet obviously so
who knows what episode this is but my
point is this is one of the early
episodes and you're listening to
congratulations
um so yeah hi and also uh this is uh
this is new to me too
and this is a podcast about a call to
congratulations I'm calling it
congratulations because I feel like I
don't know everyone needs a
congratulations from now for now and
every now and then and you know what
sometimes in a good way and sometimes in
a bad way I feel like congratulations is
good like if you're having a baby
oh great congratulations congratulations
for just being you and stick into that
and not [ __ ] up and then also
sometimes congratulations because you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] and you're and you
don't know it but but to me you know if
you got on like some kind of [ __ ]
pants or if you got you know if you're
in line and you're like dillydallyin
instead of like [ __ ] you congratulations
you know you you [ __ ] did it you're a
big [ __ ] [ __ ] anyway
enough explaining I don't want to
explain I don't explain things here's
the thing about this podcast I don't
explain things and I also don't want it
I don't want you to know too much about
me which is horrible for podcasts but
I'm doing it because I want to reach
more people and I want people to I want
people to understand me in a way but not
it not too much um so yeah so I was uh I
was in I was in Omaha this week and I
went to Omaha and I thought here's the
thing I put on it I put out a Twitter
poll saying I wanted to run my hour
because I'm about to shoot my new
special soon and I wanted to run my hour
just to get the to get the reps in and
figure it out um so I asked my agent you
know set up a place and he said okay I
got an offer for Sacramento I and I also
have an offer for Omaha which one do you
want to do and I thought for sure
because I've been a Sacramento before I
thought that people would be excited to
go to if I was going to go to Sacramento
because I've been there already and when
you see a live show you know you watch
stand-up on on on on TV it's not as good
as seeing it live it's just not no
matter no matter what stand up you're
going to see but when I went to go I've
been to Sacramento a bunch so I was like
let me put it out on Twitter I did a
Twitter poll which I don't normally do
those Twitter polls but I was like which
one should I go to Sacramento or you
could vote for Omaha and I was like
Sacramento's going to win I'm just going
to be able to do this short flight and
just get to Sacramento would be really
easy
an Omaha one so much hands down and I
feel like it's because I felt like it
was because they have nothing to do
there but then I thought about how
nobody has anything doing Sacramento
either nobody really has anything to do
except for in Los Angeles Chicago New
York Austin you know there are some
other spots like Denver thinks it's like
that but it's not you know what I mean
they just have the Rockies
I like here's it I'm going off on on
this because Denver I love I love
performing in Denver but Denver Act
there are some certain there are some
cities that act like
when you get there as a guest that
they're lucky that that you're lucky to
be there and that [ __ ] [ __ ] pisses me
off
and Denver's like that Denver you get
there and they think because they got
they did the weed thing first and their
air is really [ __ ] nice and they have
mountains that you're lucky to be there
and I and I and I'm not I'm not saying
I'm not lucky to be there but I mean
because it's a great place but don't act
like you don't act like the Rockies have
been around since [ __ ] in 1940 do you
know what I mean they were an expansion
team in the 90s and don't act like when
I go to a [ __ ] Rockies game which I
which I'm not doing I'm not I'm not
doing that I don't go to sporting events
because I don't like to be around a lot
of people like that and number two I
don't give a [ __ ] about anything really
that much but don't don't when I get
there don't act like you you know did
your [ __ ] doesn't stink I don't care
it's great your place is great Austin
it's [ __ ] great but when I get there
and you're like you got to go to some of
these places and just hear these like
you know musicians in these small bars I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm going to get the
CD but also I'm not going to get the CD
so I don't give a [ __ ] ee which leads me
to another actual problem which is
another reason why I'm doing this
podcast which will never I'm getting
really convoluted here but already which
is it's this 5th minute but I'll get
back to the Twitter poll in Omaha but I
don't I don't want to do i I don't when
I go to what am I trying to say here
okay this is one of the reasons why I
want this podcast okay one ton [ __ ] this
is so hard to explain one time when I
was at the coffee bean in tea leaf I had
this coffee bean I used to run this
[ __ ] block in Studio City when I
lived there dude I there was a Coffee
Bean and Tea Leaf a 76 station there was
a [ __ ] salad place it's not there
anymore
there was a bagel shop was not there
anymore I mean I [ __ ] ran this block
dude it was five
and it was in Studio City there was a
sushi place and the sushi place is still
there but I [ __ ] was there I was
there dude I was at this coffee bean
everyday and I ran this [ __ ] block
dude I was like I was like the Tony
Soprano of this [ __ ] of these five
store like little this block area there
was a 76 station it's not there anymore
now it's a Wells Fargo the coffee bean
is still there but it's terrible now
there it's like it's got more traffic
than the it's like you get there and it
you're like where's the protest like you
feel like what are they protesting
that's that's what it's like there's so
many [ __ ] people there and then the
the bagel place is now a five guys which
you know I love five guys but when I go
to a car I'm not going to eat five guys
at like noon
you know because I'm not a piece of [ __ ]
and then there is a there was a salad
place which was awesome dude it had the
best Cobb salad ever and they shut it
down dude they shut it down and now
there's a Fantastic Sams and the sushi
place is still there which is pretty
good and the coffee bean the where it's
like you know they're doing a March
everyday it sucks and then and then the
76 is a Wells Fargo now so I don't run
that block anymore I don't even live
there anymore but I was there every day
dude and I would I ran into this guy you
know when you're at the coffee shop it
was a little bit like friends like it
was it wasn't as cozy and cool as the
Central Perk the coffee shop that they
had there but it was the Coffee Bean and
Tea Leaf whatever you would go there and
you would see the same guy now I'm I
keep to myself I don't like you know but
occasionally I like weirdos like my
friends are always making fun of me
because I hate because they're like your
friends are so [ __ ] weird and some of
them are so [ __ ] boring
but then I say to them well would the
[ __ ] do you think you are you're my
friend as well I love weird weirdos like
I have a really tall lanky [ __ ]
string bean Italian friend and he's
[ __ ] hilarious and my other friends
are like he's such a [ __ ] you know
he's so Italian like how do you like
identify with them but I'm like I don't
want somebody I can identify with I want
some [ __ ] [ __ ] that I can like
joke around with and make fun of and
have him make fun of me back anyway
so I met this guy there that was a
stuntman and I guess he was a stuntman I
don't even know really he looked like a
stuntman to be honest he had like he was
really stocky and fit he had thick
eyebrows and uh and he had a high
pitched voice and he was a stuntman I
think but anyway he would read these
books now if you're a I read books I
read some books I do
I read certain authors that I like and
like journalism and [ __ ] I don't really
like you know I mean I read that [ __ ]
what was that Tom Hanks movie they made
if a book is huge not angels and demons
but the other one The Da Vinci Code I
read that and that was good you know for
like a [ __ ] quick like crazy read on
an airplane but this guy would read
books he'd come to the coffee shop every
day and read books and there were books
I don't give a [ __ ] about at all and but
we would talk and we would you know get
to know each other and we talked about
stunts I think he did I don't even
remember I think it was his thumb if it
wasn't a stuntman he's a stuntman now I
don't give a [ __ ] like that's just what
he is to the story and occasionally a
girl would walk in and he'd be like wow
that girl's really hot and I'd be like
yeah cool you know whatever whatever the
[ __ ] you know regular guy banter let
locker-room talk but not the [ __ ]
Trump kind so uh so one day he says to
me and I this is like years we would see
each other like year I'm telling you I
ran the block dude I ran the block so
hard once I swear to god this isn't even
a joke James Gandolfini came in once to
the coffee bean and there was like
tension and I'm not even [ __ ] around
I mean I'm joking about how the tension
was there but he came in once and I was
there already and when he walked in
because I made the Tony Soprano
reference I was like oh dude how [ __ ]
cool is it that Tony Soprano is here but
I run this block but he he didn't know
it but like I imagined he knew it so so
he got in and you'd even sit down he got
his coffee and he walked out Tony James
Gandolfini
so disrespectful by the way to call him
Tony Soprano like it is not a real
person but one of the best shows ever
great actor anyway rest in peace right
so people say but it's just so sad he
went too soon but anyway so this guy's
reading a [ __ ] book and and he says
you know you really got to read this
book to me
he says you really got to read this book
and I say look I know it's got four
years now I said what's the book and he
says it's a book on religion and about
how and I tuned out done not only with
the [ __ ] book and this talk done done
with this guy dude and you might be like
well that's a little harsh but it's not
dude I've known this guy for two years
this guy knows me this guy knows me
better than a lot of my friends this guy
knows me better than some of my family
members not immediate family but like I
have a cousin butch you know and like
for him to be like I don't know you
enough after these two years we spend
every single day together that you
wouldn't literally use pages of this
book to wipe your [ __ ] after you took
a [ __ ] I don't know you well enough to
where if there was note if there was if
there was Tyla taper in the bathroom and
it was too far and this book was close
enough you might actually use pages of
this book to wipe your ass after you
took a [ __ ] but I'm going to take this
book and I'm gonna [ __ ] recommend it
to you even though I know you and you're
not going to not only read this book but
if you did because here's the other
things like well maybe he wants you to
learn a little bit about and it's okay
because your friend fine but then he
doesn't know me well enough to know that
if I read that book I wouldn't [ __ ]
hate that book that's so [ __ ]
disrespectful to know somebody and be
like here we did dude if I [ __ ] all
of a sudden say if I all of a sudden say
to my friend dude you got to read this
book about how they make planes and my
buddy is like this guy who doesn't ever
give a [ __ ] about planes and doesn't
like
Planes then I'm an [ __ ] I'm a
complete piece of [ __ ] so so that was
that I didn't read the book and then I
was like ah that was kind of honestly
that was how the block fell in my head
in my mind that was how I [ __ ] was
like dude this is changing and then ever
and then since then the 76 station
became the Wells Fargo the bagel place
became the five guys and the salad
plates went out of business and I'm not
[ __ ] around and I'm not saying that
that's why but I'm just saying it's a
little bit [ __ ] as Tony Soprano would
say ironical um so yeah so so I don't
even know how the [ __ ] I got but that's
how this is going to be though I don't
even give it I don't know how I got I'll
get back to the Twitter poll but that's
how this is gonna be I don't know I went
off on a tangent I have no idea how to
get back but I'm not sorry about it and
and so so I put up this Twitter poll um
and I said look you know I'm gonna go to
Sacramento or I'm going to go to Omaha
and and they were like and I was like
whichever gets the most votes I'll go
and they were like okay and Omaha just
won hands down so now I'm like [ __ ] I
got to go to Omaha I got to take this
long flight which wasn't that long
actually I thought was gonna be like
four hours it was like two and a half so
I gotta go Omaha and I gotta be like
there's nothing to do here and it's so
cold but that's what Sacramento is like
nothing is there's nothing to do there
at least it wasn't in this summertime in
Sacramento honestly I went to [ __ ]
Sacramento in like August once and I
swear to God I swear to god it was so
hot that when I went what did you it was
the kind of hot where like you would
leave to go to Starbucks and you'd come
back and then you go to put it you'd
like put your like because you're
wearing like a short sleeve shirt or a
tank top because you're in Sacramento
and you where you'd lean up against the
seatbelt and it would be scorching lava
and you were you so hot were you like
the belt would get so hot that you
literally don't even know what's
happening you're not like you know
there's a kind of hot we're gonna like
where it's like so hot we're like oh
[ __ ] that's hot but then there's the
kind of hot where you're like oh
getting abducted right now like what's
happening that's the kind of [ __ ] hot
that seatbelt gets in Sacramento and it
was so hot I used to do this joke on
stage when I was in Sacramento I was I'm
remembering now about how it was so hot
that when I would go to Starbucks I
would come back and it was like a
[ __ ] sauna like there was I would
look in the back seat and there would be
an Asian guy with a towel on like an old
Asian guy be like white and he'd be like
a why are you into my Sona it's so
stupid but um but yeah but but and you
know and then one guy was like tweeted
me afterwards like that's racist and I'm
like nah old Asian dudes love [ __ ]
saunas you know that's just kind of how
it is almost as much as like white
chicks um so uh so yeah so I put out
this poll and then [ __ ] Omaha won
hands down and I'm like I gotta go to
Omaha and so I [ __ ] got to Omaha and
it was it was it was uh my travel agent
was like I got you in the the best kind
of version of the hotel that they have
and I stayed at this [ __ ] hotel and
it was good it had a gym which would the
heat was on because they were like oh
it's so cold we got to put the heat on
and the heat was on the gym is so
[ __ ] that was a sauna but anyway it
was beautiful there it was beautiful and
I don't mean like it wasn't Yosemite
don't get me wrong it wasn't that kind
of beautiful but it was yeah it was like
real crisp air and you know come from in
LA so there's smog everywhere in traffic
but it was awesome the ubers would pick
you up and have conversations with you
um and they were nice and polite I
forget because I live you know a lot of
you guys probably listening to this in
in places like Omaha I live in LA in New
York and yeah I go to New York a lot and
I go to like these big cities and to
play a plays big cities a lot people are
like but and I should say though only
it's mostly LA though not even New York
people think of New York as like people
are [ __ ] but they're not though dude
they have this front like they're like
that but they're not in LA people are
[ __ ] legit [ __ ] and you got to
you got to catch yourself sometimes
because sometimes you're you know I'm
one
but so I went to Omaha and it was it was
it was great man the crowds were awesome
I played the Omaha funnybone it was
great the the owner there or was so nice
and the staff there was great and the
crowds were awesome uh and I had a great
time on stage and I ran an hour and I'm
you know I've been ready to shoot it but
it feels good to to be able to shoot it
to you know to run the run the set and
do it I thought I got this new little
bit I'm doing here
and and I added it to it so you know I
don't know when an hour's done but you
got a figure um you got a figure uh you
know it's done when you I wanted to
shoot it last year but my agents were
like hold off tour with it a little bit
so now it's it is way better now but
then you got these guys like bill burr
that do an hour every four months and
louis c.k and and and and jeff and jim
jeffries said to me the other day he was
like not the other day I guess it was a
while ago because all you got to do one
every every hour every hour every year
man that's what the greats do and I was
like yeah [ __ ] maybe I do but then I was
like yeah then my agent was like how
many specials you want to do in your
life and I was like [ __ ] that's a good
point what do I want to have I'm young
ish you know what I mean why we're gonna
do one every year I'm gonna have 57
specials by the time I die then they're
not really that special you know I'm not
saying that people who do that specials
aren't special I think that obviously
louis c.k and bill bird you know and jim
jefferies they all got great special
specials but I can't imagine doing that
many and then thinking that mine were
that special so anyway anyway I'm unlike
the to a mama like a year and a half two
year plan maybe I'll let me go wait a
little longer to do my next one but also
the second you put out your special like
when I had incorrigible come out the day
later people were like we need more
when's the next one and it's like at
least let me [ __ ] be happy about this
and and and like take in the
tweet and like the time that I'm uh that
I get to like it came out let me be
proud of it a little bit is what I'm
saying but uh but yeah so anyway it's
ready I'm shooting it I'm shooting it in
Vancouver I was gonna shoot it in
Atlanta because I love shooting in
Atlanta
I'm sorry I love performing in Atlanta
and and I love I love I love performing
in Atlanta and every time I was going to
Atlanta every time I would I would say
to people I was going to shoot in
Atlanta other commuters like really I
was like yeah why and they were like I
don't know it just surprised me that you
would shoot in Atlanta and I think I
think that's racist
not not actually [ __ ] I don't think
you're a racist
really I guess when you say that but
when you say that I think what they're
thinking is you're a white guy though
which which is stupid because when I go
to perform in Atlanta mostly the
audience is the more audiences are mixed
it's not I think I think people think of
Atlanta as like only black people and
it's not it's like this [ __ ] city
that has everybody in it and I love that
about about cities about performing in
cities because you get to [ __ ]
perform from whatever a melting pot I
was think it's corny when people say
that but like you - you know when you go
out dude I used to play La Joya all the
time and I hated it because it was
legitimately only white people and it
was annoying they were all wearing like
button-downs and shorts and sandals and
I wanted to kick every one of them in
the face because don't be so light like
that you know what I mean don't be so
how about this and I tried to do this on
stage once and it came off kind of
racist but don't be look if you're too
much that way look if you're a [ __ ]
fat guy that's fine be fat be proud to
be in fat but if you're this fat guy
that's like num-num I always want to eat
and I'm um you know or like or like
always looking at Donuts and you're like
nah
good the [ __ ] like that's so annoying
that's so annoying that you're that much
that guy and I know that that sounds
like I'm I'm I'm sort of like this like
I don't know what would it be like a
dictator where I'm like nah we all have
to conform this certain way but I don't
really mean that you know but if you're
like a frat guy and you wear bandanas
around your [ __ ] head and like you
say stuff like Oh classic you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't I like you gotta
here's the deal you're not maybe not
NASA maybe you're a good guy maybe give
to charity and [ __ ] like that but prove
to me you're not an [ __ ] that's the
thought I have so if you're this you
know guy who who is you know in La Jolla
and a white guy and you've got this
button-down and the cargo shorts and the
sandals proved to me you're not an
[ __ ] and that's the thing with you I
like multi national multi cultural multi
colored [ __ ] people in my audience
because it's more fun because then I
know I can reach a more more types of
people so I stopped doing law because of
that um now that being said La Jolla is
gorgeous and it's awesome but uh but
yeah uh I'm so I'm a Lea nating all
these [ __ ] cities here I literally
said [ __ ] Denver [ __ ] La Jolla [ __ ]
Austin I don't mean [ __ ] all these
places you know what I'm talking about
here's the thing you know what I'm
[ __ ] talking about and if you don't
know what I'm talking about
you're probably the problem yeah let's
go to a you know Seattle and grow a
beard and and have shorter hair on the
top of my head than my face beard and
wear flannel only and say [ __ ] Starbucks
do you know I'm talking about prove to
me you're not an [ __ ] if you're that
way um
so so yeah I don't even remember what
the [ __ ] I was talking about but was I
talking about dude do you even know this
is my producer but he has no idea I was
talking about uh La Jolla and anyway
this is how it is I should call this
[ __ ] podcast off track um that's
probably a better name maybe I'll switch
it this is only the second episode um so
uh yeah anyway I don't know what I was
talking about but not [ __ ] Denver you
know what I'm talking about if you don't
know what I'm talking about you're part
of the problem
oh yeah yeah yeah I was talking about a
fat guy but being that but yeah but that
was already I was already in the I was
already off track but at that point
anyway uh I don't remember I guess this
is when Mike this is when I if if I were
my cousin I would say welcome to my
world my cousin when he was a kid he
would say walk in my world all the time
and we would [ __ ] laughed so hard and
he had this voice when he was a kid
where he would like talk like this and
he would like talk like this and my
brother and I would laugh every time
he'd be like welcome to my world like
it's so funny for like a
fourteen-year-old to say that what's
your world welcome to my world will you
mean like would you like what's your
world you have a tutor you know um so
yeah but already this is 25 minutes in
and I literally don't know what the [ __ ]
by the way I have this [ __ ] this is
another thing too I have a my British
friend just texted me and this is how
this is how this is the this is actually
and I always talk to him because he'll
it's so British to [ __ ] email
somebody instead of text them like
that's that's the thing like he's
actually that British as I was talking
about like you like there are so white
guys in la jolla
like he'll [ __ ] email me a picture
and I'm like bro what
wrong with [ __ ] SMS or multimeter the
MMMs whatever the [ __ ] it's called the
text message I guess that would be
multimedia [ __ ] but so I never know if
he's in Britain or he was a guy on
undateable um David Finn great actor
hilarious good guy love him but he'll be
like he'll I'll be like yes I made a
picture and then I'll be like you didn't
submit a picture and be like check your
email and I'll check my email and it'll
be the picture be there and why didn't
you [ __ ] to text me and I'll be like
I cuz I'm British um but uh he texts and
so he texts me too good for [ __ ] and
dogs now too good for [ __ ] and dogs now
bro and that's how Friday I don't know
what that [ __ ] means so literally 40
minutes later I got the text and I
texted him back what bro Friday goes by
no no no if I didn't go by then five
hours later I text him back in the
all-caps
oh cool because he didn't text me back
you get an old cool from me [ __ ] that if
you didn't text somebody back in five
hours and it's the daytime so then I
text them back five hours later oh cool
and then the next day twenty hours later
now we're talking about he writes tagged
you in something on IG yesterday nice
that you thought about it in the four
hours between your two texts though so
doesn't explain it which makes me which
actually makes me furious - because
explain it dude what do you got to do
that you can't just [ __ ] explain it
okay so then I don't write back because
I'm like angry like friend angry not
like angry angry and then then he just
texted me now a day later
only just saw this message didn't send
the other day with a been pointing above
it and it did come through we're like
and all of the text messages are green
I was so British dude I don't know where
he is he's in Great Britain for sure no
he said he was in town too
I don't know but this is the most
British [ __ ] ever like it take three
days for this to have a conversation in
a text only just saw this message didn't
send the other day Oh got it first of
all got it also didn't make sense and
don't explain how you thought I didn't
get the [ __ ] message explain the
goddamn message too good for [ __ ] and
dogs now bro he sets dude also expect
that I would get that not now this
sounds pompous but I have so many
[ __ ] I have seven over 700,000
followers on Instagram this guy tags me
in something rather than tech that's
also so British
send me the [ __ ] thing dude on text
anyway so that's that's so I don't know
what he means and I'm gonna ask him
again when I see him which who knows I
did undateable with him that's a when
you do a show with somebody like he's
he's like one of my favorite people and
when you do a show with somebody you
talk to them every day and then the show
gets canceled and like you literally
never hear from them ever again and it's
it's kind of sad I guess if you thought
about it I don't think about it that
much which makes it even more sad but
like you don't if you're not a comedian
you're not in my life which is so sad
because I see them all the time at the
Comedy Store The Improv the Laugh
Factory whatever but like I don't like
like what it like you know Kiefer
Sutherland hasn't talked to that guy
Dennis Haysbert in [ __ ] 12 years or
whatever 24 was not and Kiefer
Sutherland sees those Allstate
commercials and he's like
I remember him oh he was a good guy and
Dennis Haysbert sees whatever the [ __ ]
designated survivor and he's like he's
like all you remember him you know those
two guys have the most voices voices and
they were on the same show and they have
fond memories of each other but they
literally haven't seen each other since
Dennis Haysbert was assassinated in
season four in [ __ ] 24 whatever it
was and and and and key for southern
room because Sutherland was like we'll
have to get that coffee in a week you
know and then his Hesburgh was like I'll
be free I'm wide open because he
literally doesn't have it didn't was on
the show anymore and and they had plans
to go get coffee
at like 4:00 p.m. in Brentwood you know
because that's for sure all 100% where
Dennis Haysbert lived is if Dennis
Haysbert doesn't live in Brentwood
I'll [ __ ] jump off that [ __ ]
suicide bridge in Pasadena there's no I
don't know that for sure
but we're actually Google where he lives
will you this is something my producer
can do Google where Dennis Haysbert has
a house but don't say the address but
there's no way he doesn't live in
Brentwood um and then never saw him
again ever it literally hasn't seen him
again ever
maybe this one wants out like the SAG
Awards or something but like saw them
from afar and like was like hey you do
and he was like good it's been really
good and that's it Malibu so I mean same
thing like Malibu and Brentwood is so
far it is it's such a like I live in LA
but I don't live in LA kind of a vibe
thing that it's like the same thing if
you live in there's nothing more LA
there's nothing more LA than living in
Brentwood except for living in Malibu
the only place more LA it is to live in
Malibu is Paris I heard Johnny Depp
lived in Paris
I heard Johnny Depp not he didn't have a
place in Paris I heard his home was in
Paris and I almost ate my own dick
that's how la it is I was like oh
course Johnny Depp lives in Paris
because he's the most Hollywood guy
there is and I know people who know
Johnny Depp a hundred percent would say
to me right now oh you don't know Johnny
Depp though and he's actually not LA in
which I would respond he wears two hats
at the same time sometime you'd be like
oh I actually know Johnny Depp he's not
Los Angeles in which I would respond
he's got 47 skull rings you know he
wears a tent though do you know what I'm
saying
so so you don't get to say he's not
Hollywood because here's who knows if
somebody's Hollywood or not somebody who
just kind of pays attention to somebody
if you're a friend of somebody there are
people who would say I'm Hollywood for
sure my friends would be like no he's
not Hollywood but but dude it's not up
to your friends to tell you that it's up
to the people who kind to know you and
see you in magazines I'm not in
magazines I'm talk about Johnny Depp so
that's the most when I heard Johnny Depp
lives in Paris I cuz actually you know
what that's actually where this came
from one time I was think I was talking
to my uncle and he said I said yeah
Johnny Depp it must be so Hollywood and
he said oh no you know he lives in Paris
and I said that's it that's it that's
the most that's the most Hollywood [ __ ]
ever is to live in Paris not have a home
there but to live and I'm sure he's got
a home in LA - I'm sure it's in Malibu
but but yeah so that's that's the most
LA place to live is Paris I think John
Malkovich lives there too so that's like
there you go mmm by the way Johnny Depp
jump I'm John Malkovich great at what
they do I'm not knocking on them so [ __ ]
you with that [ __ ] when you know because
I know that shit's coming my way with
the seven listeners I have so far but
yeah they're great they're great at what
they do there to the top not from other
[ __ ] Johnny Depp John Malkovich both
great up being actors Johnny Depp also
great up being it's a Hollywood
so yeah so that's what's up again I got
off track but yeah so anyway oh so
that's what I was trying to say I mean I
haven't I literally haven't seen David
since we the season finale of undateable
season 3 which by the way we did three
seasons in five days people were like I
was on for that long but it was not kind
of but it was three seasons but NBC did
it in like two years so it didn't seem
it seemed like it Mb these NBC will do
this thing where it's like season three
four months later and you're like okay
and B I don't think audience members
kind of catch up to that but whatever
Ron Funches will not show he's got that
new show called powerless on NBC which
you should check out um great cast great
guys on that um but yeah so so so that's
got it really is so Hollywood though
like if I got a place in Omaha that
would be so [ __ ] Hollywood you know
what if I got a place in Omaha if I
lived in Omaha and not LA I feel like I
would probably get more work because
people would be like Oh
digitally there's an Omaha people I want
really you think he's available for John
wick 3 to play the bad guy and then
people be like I'd be kind of cool
because it kind of looks like a kind of
Reeves if he didn't if he didn't sleep
that much um I would love to [ __ ] by
the way two of the top people I would
love to do movies with who I actually
think are great actors counter Reeves
and Nicolas Cage Nicolas Cage has their
career that is the best career and I
heard Sean Penn I was reading about Sean
Penn talking [ __ ] about how Nicolas Cage
used to be an actor and then I heard
Nicolas Cage said like so many people
talk [ __ ] it's tough when your friends
talk [ __ ] or something
maybe I made that up maybe I made that
whole thing up but I think it happened
because I think I remember reading
[ __ ] that dude Nicolas Cage did the
movie where he like did it he did
leaving Las Vegas and then was like I'm
gonna do movies where I get to drive
into buildings in my in cars or drive
out of buildings on my car and just like
he broke so many [ __ ] windows in all
these movies and [ __ ] had to how many
movies has Johnny Depp done or I'm sorry
enough Johnny Depp how many movies has
Nicolas Cage done where he has to talk
to a guy from the underworld that's not
the [ __ ] devil but a henchman for the
devil Nicolas Cage is done since leaving
Las Vegas Nicolas Cage has done 14
movies where he's had to talk to a
devil's henchman and those 14 movies are
my favorite movies and those are the
movies I want to do after I do the crazy
[ __ ] I want to get to a point where
no [ __ ] I want to play an Asian man
in a drama with no makeup and I want to
do it and I want to win a [ __ ] SAG
Award for it because I want them to be
like did you see that [ __ ] did you
see Chris D'Elia the but don't [ __ ] my
name up because I'm not going to be that
famous they'll be like did you see Chris
- Elia Oh Chris Delilah did the did that
movie maybe like what is it what is it
what what movie and they'll be like he
plays it a a Japanese guy it like really
is it funny and they'll be like not it's
not a comedy and they'll be like what do
you mean it's not a comedy and they'll
be like it's a it's a drama about a
Japanese guy who plays a Japanese guy
who like lost his daughter and you're
like what well then it's funnier than it
would even be if it was a comedy be like
dude that's what I thought but you've
got to see it and then people go see it
and they'll be like whoa he's it's weird
like he's like Japanese in the movie but
he did not wearing makeup but he's good
that's my goal to play a foot when I'm
like 45 or 46 to play a Japanese guy you
know I don't know where it would be
maybe it would be like I don't know what
where where would take place I want
somebody to
right it but uh but I want to develop it
with them but then and then to be a
drama and to where I like do like I have
like maybe one scene where my might it's
not overboard rum like crying so hard
but like there's one scene where I like
I'm welling up and and and I'm but I'm
and I'm you know you kind of forget that
I'm playing like this Japanese guy but
like you're also kind of like it's in
the back your head still a little bit
and then I win a SAG Award for it and I
almost went an Oscar but I get beat by
like you know I get beat by like Jordan
goes 11 Joseph gordon-levitt at the
[ __ ] and because he come finally wins
his [ __ ] after doing all those [ __ ]
movies that he did we play like man on a
wire or whatever that movie was the walk
but but and I like and then Snowden and
then he had his [ __ ] movies were like
this is the movie see he's always wanted
to make and he wins and he's like he's
probably I guess he's PI my age so he's
46 and he won he beat me and people are
like there are people that are like
pissed off because like Chris D'Elia
deserved it you know because he played a
Japanese guy without being in and in the
Japanese community community is like he
deserves it because he played us without
being like overly you know stereotypical
and but then also some people do think
it's racist but you know because you
always got this but all those people are
white people that live in [ __ ] la
jolla because it's those people that get
pissed off not the actual people that
should get pissed off and then after
that movie straight up
I do 15 movies where the bad guy is a
henchman to the devil in the underworld
that's that's my goal no [ __ ] that's
my goal and they're all action movies I
Drive out of [ __ ] buildings with cars
and the bad guy is always you know the
character is the henchman of the devil
but the the hench the actual bad guy is
always like you know some foreign guy
that's like you know has like a series
on NBC or ABC but like he was like a and
it's like kind of watched but not
but he's always got a big he's got like
a big following in like Germany the [ __ ]
am I talking about I don't know but
anyway that's what it is but so I I
think I'm going to wrap this up dude
it's been 41 minutes you know we'll grow
as you guys grow but yeah so that's what
we learned
Omaha is a great place to visit for
three days I had a great time there the
audiences were awesome Thank You Omaha
we learned that actors don't keep in
touch and I guess it's a shame I would
like Kiefer Sutherland to reach out to
Dennis Haysbert and see how he's doing
kind of catch up and go get that coffee
that they were talking about that you
know they were talking about you guys
can meet in Brentwood how's that because
you know kids giver selling at least
lives in Brentwood and we learned that
Johnny Depp is so Hollywood for living
in Paris and that's the most Hollywood
place to live and somebody write me my
Japanese movie my drama but you got ten
years you got 11 years to make it before
I'm 50 you got 15 years so thanks this
has been episode whichever of
congratulations and you can tweet me
questions by using the hashtag
congratulations pod and I'll address
them if they're not [ __ ] idiot
questions you know uh so yeah that's it
thanks for listening and oh you can
check me out on tour Chris D'Elia calm
and I'm going to all sorts of different
cities I'm adding all sorts of cities I
got a rally city I got in doing rally in
I never know if that's in North Carolina
or South Carolina's in North Carolina
and then I'm doing Australia too going
to Australia and then I'm going to
a wherever Tempe Arizona or something
but yeah look at it and then follow me
on all that [ __ ] Instagram Twitter
that's just Chris D'Elia and I have a
good one all right thanks bye guys a
July see we're gonna hit this [ __ ]
right
[Music]